so we have an ellipse graph right over
here what we're going to try to do is
find the equation for this ellipse so
like always pause this video and see if
you can figure it out on your own
all right so let's just remind ourselves
the form of an equation of ellipse so
let's say our ellipse is centered
at the point so i'm going to speak in
generalities first and then we'll think
about the specific numbers for this
particular ellipse so say the center is
at the point h comma k
and let's say that you have a horizontal
radius so the radius in the x direction
horizontal
radius
radius is equal to a
and let's say your vertical radius
let's say your vertical radius
radius
is equal to b
then your the equation of this ellipse
is going to be is going to be
x
minus
h
x minus
h
squared
over your horizontal radius squared so
your radius in the x direction squared
plus
plus now we'll think about what we're
doing in the vertical direction
y
minus the y minus the y coordinate of
our center
so y minus
k
squared
over the vertical radius squared b
squared is equal to 1
is equal to 1.
so what are h and k and a and b in this
situation well h and k are pretty easy
to figure out the center
of this ellipse is at the point see the
x coordinate is negative 4
and the y coordinate is three
so this right over here is negative four
and this right over here is positive
three
and what is a going to be
well a is your horizontal radius your
radius in the horizontal direction so
it's the length of this line right over
here and we can see it's 1 2 3 4 5 units
long so a in this case is equal to 5 so
this is going to be 5 squared
and b is our radius of the vertical
direction we can see it's one two three
four units so b
is equal to four so that is four so we
can rewrite this as
we could rewrite this as x minus
negative 4
and we can simplify that in a second
x minus negative 4 squared
over 5 squared over our horizontal
radius squared so it's going to be
25 plus
y
minus 3 squared
y
minus the y coordinate of our center
y minus 3
squared
over our vertical radius squared so b
squared is going to be 16 and that is
going to be equal to 1.
and of course we could simplify this a
little bit if i subtract a negative
that's the same thing as adding a
positive
so i can get rid of
i can just instead of saying x minus
negative 4 i could just say x
plus 4. and there you have it we have
the equation for this ellipse